the Clark County School District is
still trying to hire Educators as the
teacher's shortage expands now across
the country there's a new study out
showing Nevada is in the top two for
states with the most teacher vacancies
Victoria Saha digs into why teachers are
leaving and what's being done about it
keep them
there are two big issues here that seem
to affect the teacher's shortage they're
being overworked and they're underpaid
and as we wrap up almost week two of the
new school year there are still hundreds
of jobs open Clark County is home to the
fifth largest school district in the
country with more than 320 000 students
right now many of those students are
without a designated teacher I think
what I miss the most is just the kids
and the relationship part and my
colleagues Lauren Burleson is a middle
school teacher and has been with the
district for five years but this year
she's taking a break from the classroom
just the stress level is really high
Burleson says it wasn't an easy decision
but a necessary one as health issues and
workload became too much my prep was
taken almost every single day I was
subbing every day for someone a teacher
who was out so you're doing your job
plus another teacher's job yep CCSD says
they have added incentives to recruit
more teachers such as starting pay at
fifty thousand dollars and giving a
relocation bonus but Burleson wants
veteran teachers to be valued first I
would be making the same starting salary
as somebody walking right into the
classroom and Marie nieces with the
Clark County Education Association says
fighting to get more benefits for
teachers will be an ongoing battle now
we need to make sure we focus on
retaining our Educators that we do have
here and that's the fight that CCA will
take on once again during Carson City as
of Wednesday CCSD says they have hired
over 1300 teachers and they continue to
hire daily Victoria zaha eight news now
CCSD recruits at colleges and job fairs
all across the country they also have
the J-1 Visa which allows teachers from
the Philippines to teach in the special
ed department but the union says the
Visa only allows for them to stay five
years which will also contribute to the
teacher shortage long term